[Music]
what have you done to make the world a
better place
well I'm trying to make an exoskeleton
right now like a little robotic suit
that you could put on to help people
walk I had a spinal cord injury three
years ago so I'm paralyzed and I can't
walk back
I feel like robotics technology is just
improving so rapidly I'm trying my best
to see if we can apply the newest
robotics technology to help make this
actual thing to be able to get people
walking on a day to day setting because
right now the exoskeletons are kind of
dumb they they don't walk very well you
gotta use crutches still and it's very
unlike a medical hospital setting you
still gonna have people watching over
but I think the technology is there for
us to be able to build something that I
could use on a day to day setting you
know get upstairs and I think it would
mean a lot to a lot of the other parts
of the world I feel like we're very
fortunate here in California there's a
DA and there's a lot of places with
ramps and everything but I I just went
back to China a few months ago and I was
visiting my grandparents and it is so
inaccessible they're the smallest things
like getting off the curb to cross the
road there's no there's no like curb cut
out so you gotta take a step down and I
can't so I just can't cross the roads
and that's just one of the small things
but like a lot of people in these in
these countries literally can't get
around they're just bedridden for the
rest of their lives which is a shame
because I think there's a lot of there's
a lot of talent pool out there within
these people but they just can't express
themselves because they're limited by
the mobility
yeah what I am doing to make the world a
better place is bringing more stories
with people who look like me to I don't
know the forefront or the foreground so
I guess popularizing those and I think
representation just helps us identify
with each other more I've written
children of blood and bone and I guess
technically children are virtue and
vengeance and I plan on writing another
one but I shall not reveal the title
since August last year once a week I
walk around in my neighborhood like just
a block like in kilometres I think three
or four kilometres and I take rubbish
from Street so now I've done that forty
five times to try to get the streets a
little bit more cleaner and make sure
that the rubbish isn't picked up by
animals or whatever it's one year now so
I'm quite happy and I'll try to do to do
it as long as possible if you want to
try it yourself
go ahead would be nice the world will
thank you
and I'm sure that you will have nice day
I think what we've done so far is over
the past like two years we together
started a nonprofit called the one
frontier and it is intended for queer
Christians or queer people of any faith
to kind of come to terms with
reconciling both their sexuality or
their gender expression and their
religion or whatever they identify with
spiritually because it's scary and like
you know you hear a lot of people who
like end up committing suicide over
so like tormenting to have to like think
about these two things especially if
you've been like raised in the church
and and all that stuff so yeah so what
are your stories and why did you guys
personally want to dance yeah so
personally we individually we have gone
on our own journeys of like reconciling
our own faith and sexuality like we both
identify as like gay Christians and we
went through the whole thing of like
realizing that we're gay and then also
realizing like wait how does that affect
it's like our relationship with Christ
personally for me like my history and my
background is growing up in a Christian
faith and a very conservative Christian
faith is where a lot of my background is
and so we know the struggles that come
with trying to reconcile both your faith
and your queerness and we just have a
lot of experience on that I think we
just really want to help other people
because we know that it's possible and I
think what we intend to do in the future
is to start a like an actual in-person
meetup here in San Diego where people
can kind of come together and talk and
ask hard questions in a safe space where
they're not going to feel like they're
going to be judged and just hope to like
cultivate like a space of acceptance and
love in a weird kind of controversial
space that normally doesn't promote
acceptance and love our website is the
one frontier calm and our YouTube
channel if you just type in angel and
Nicole we should we should pop up I am
going to stop using Amazon because the
supply chain has really gotten out of
hand
has a huge footprint so basically just
as consumers everything we consume has
an impact on in emissions and climate
change in the environment and we get
used to clicking a button and having
something from around the world develop
like deliver to us then we don't really
realize that the print on it has and so
especially with Amazon you often like
don't know where the stuff you're buying
comes from and for your convenience it's
getting shipped from like halfway around
the world and you know plane fuel is one
of the highest contributors greenhouse
gases and there's just a lot of waste
involved in our supply chain that's
subsidized for our convenience I do yes
I use Amazon Prime
I'm reliant on it I got three things
from Amazon trying this okay so so your
goal is that if I were to follow up with
you on the air you would say that you
don't use it yes it's hard for you to
commit to it yes guys that's my goal
okay thank you it's funny you should ask
that I'm currently in the process of
doing that right
I'm super passionate about veganism as a
movement what a lot of people kind of
don't realize is the underlying
philosophy of veganism it's actually
really simple it's just the idea that
animals deserve to be treated with
kindness respect and compassion I think
that's a philosophy that most people
would agree aligns with their morals
their values and that's why I have this
sign here this is your morals aligned
with veganism so when I'm speaking to
people about veganism I definitely take
an approach that's not antagonistic or
argumentative and I don't want to have
debates with people I just want to have
respectful conversations vegans have a
stereotype of being judgmental and
truthfully I'm not judgmental to anyone
that eats meat because it's uh it's so
normalized in culture you can't get
angry at someone for for doing what
they've been brought up to do most
people just haven't made the connection
between their consumption choices and
the violence that is associated so I
discovered veganism at a pretty young
age that was I was 14 years old was back
in 1998 it came to me on a family
vacation we stopped that one of I
believe it was one of the river guides
house and they had the mounted heads of
all these animals they had hunted and I
just walked in this room and just filled
me with rage and that was the moment as
a camp done I'm not gonna eat meat
anymore I think when you look at it
through an objective lens the philosophy
of veganism objectively makes the most
sense because aside from the ethical
aspect of unnecessarily killing an
animal because we like the way it tastes
you have the environmental impact some
people don't know that the animal
agriculture industry is the leading
contributor to greenhouse gases it's the
leading cause of deforestation in the
Amazon
ocean dead zones acidification top soil
degradation it's just it's truly an
environmental disaster and in every way
and it's not about teaching people or
preaching to people it's more about
getting getting someone to think about a
position or a perspective that they
otherwise hadn't thought of and doing
the research on their own I don't want
anyone to trust what I'm telling them
just look into it yourself and you'll
you'll find the truth so my goal with
doing vegan outreach is definitely to
work to a position where I can do this
every day I really love doing it it's
super fulfilling I would be elated if I
could do this full-time and somehow earn
a living through it through whether it's
YouTube or you know partnerships or
however so in September I hiked the John
Muir Trail and my friend Alex and I
interviewed all of the women that we met
and well I feel that that makes the
world a better place is that when you
get an individual to open up about their
own experience and allow themselves the
space to be proud of what they are
accomplishing and I'm sure you know just
going up to someone and being so
interested in them as a human and their
personal story it brings this light out
of people
and I want to do that for the rest of my
life just having intentional
conversations and asking questions and
allowing people the space to reflect on
why what they've done is so important
and special so with all the women that
we interviewed on the JMT and then all
the people we interviewed on our road
trip over the summer we'll be making two
documentaries one about small towns two
summits and then one women of the JMT
the name will probably be changed it'll
feature the female experience of through
hiking and just what we can all gain
from nature and learn from each other
well one thing that I've been doing for
like at least the past six to nine
months is like trying to reduce my food
waste it just kind of obscene like how
much food we throw away at the end of
like not just each month but each day
and like I'm from a family of five and
just like reminding the people that
you're with like hey think about what
you have and especially the place like
San Diego like even spending day ababa
like you see homeless people around here
and you just have to think like how much
they would want to have what we have and
like the fact that we can just throw it
in the trashcan and zip in a landfill
it's kind of obscene um so yeah like one
way to like make the road a better place
to just clean up after yourself watch
off yourself make sure you're not you
know making the landfill any deeper than
it needs to be yeah you have like any
goals that align with that in the future
that you want to do like kind of expand
on that or no um I guess something
really out there I saw on a YouTube
video one time this girl she like had a
whole year of her waist like in a mason
jar and it was like all her like waist
for a whole year so I think it's like
everyone could get down to just like
filling up one mason jar for a whole
year of their ways that would be really
awesome so maybe getting at that point
yeah that's your goal yeah okay so the
cool thing about was that this project
that I'm doing
I want to like follow up with people in
a year and see like if they've kept up
with what they said they were gonna do
so would you be down to like try to do
that and then end the year yeah that'd
be awesome it kind of gives me a reason
to push myself to do it yeah I'd love to
okay so I'll reach out to you new year
awesome everyone before you go I just
wanna let you know that I put together a
playlist of episodes similar to the one
you just watched
so if you liked this episode make sure
to check that out it'll be linked
somewhere on the screen that's pretty
much it I'll see you guys next week
[Music]